une production du studio sfr
[Musique]
sans filtre le podcast on parle de ce
conte avec nos invités date si tu
cherches quentin avec moins d'hommes
plantes pour une des rares fois on se
retrouve ici dans l'espace le boudoir
qui est un espace où on one qu'ajoie ou
est ce que c'est a misé ses chaleureux
et qui disponible pour location dès
maintenant si vous avez un projet de
podcasts si vous avez un projet
d'entrevue si vous avez un web
séminaires ou un livre audio vous pouvez
louer les espaces du sf ça vient avec
tout tout tout tout et quand je dis tous
je veux dire tout c'est bien compris
tous allés aux infos non pardon écrit
nos infos au studio certes moins six ans
où aller au studio s'est pressé à cette
semaine aujourd'hui enfin podcast bien
spécial aujourd'hui on célèbre jemmapes
tirent dessus pour célébrer on célèbre
le 200e épisode du sang quelques
podcasts 200 épisodes c'est beaucoup de
discussions c'est beaucoup d'heures de
conversation ça a été toute une aventure
c'est encore toutes nos aventures
aujourd'hui enfin de mise à jour de ce
qui se passe avec le sans filtre avec
nous de ce qui s'est passé dernièrement
dans nos vies puis c'est quoi le futur
sans filtre y ait beaucoup de remises en
question beaucoup de d'idées qui ont été
brassé beaucoup de
choses ou sans filtre podcast qui pour
découvrir tout ce que coûte et les seuls
qui vous allez en apprendre un peu plus
sur nous sur nos projets sur notre passé
notre présent et notre futur
puis examinés sont puis on vous remercie
d'être là après 200 épisodes êtes encore
fidèles au poste qui est
qui fidèle au poste qui on en est
éternellement reconnaissant c'est
incroyable de vis convient de pouvoir
faire ce projet les c'est un gars du
village qui vous est
le podcast cette semaine et présenté par
nos amis chez moi ce que m'a indiqué m y
sont le world's leading donc les leaders
mondial dans tout ce qui est entretien
de l'homme de la peau du poil telle
odeur lyon le ultra premium collection
qui est moi c'est moqueur shampoing de
en enchantant de en main gel pour le
corps pour la douche
un spray comme ceux hydratant sauce et
honnêtement la meilleure chose au monde
c'est la meilleure chose au monde que
c'est mon droit d'hui préféré je suis
sérieux j'ai tout le temps la prochaine
vendange est un club stade rien à voir à
pau sèche ça c'est une bruine qui tenait
surtout avec l'odeur l'odeur unique de
mesquer qu'on retrouve dans l'or aussi
leur parfum we find c'est mon parfum je
me fais complimenté son odeur
honnêtement j'en ai pleuré tellement
c'est les meilleurs produits au monde je
suis sérieux car ce sa personne mais
skype leur style bercy moi c'est moi
c'est la mort si on a de la marque à 3-0
tableau électrique va tellement bien y
voir leproux pour l'emmener dans la
douche fait danser tout x26 il décide il
fait pour vos ballerines à fond pour
faire puisque vous les mouches bétail la
bad avec ce mot tellement bien sûr faire
une démonstration à l'argent
mais il va vraiment vraiment bien pour
n'importe quoi je vous le recommande
technologie qui fait que vous coupez
pour ses ouailles pour comme j'ai dit
c'est vraiment de groupe de minsk et
même sketch c'est incroyable il ya
encore plusieurs autres produits qu'on
vous parlait dans d'autres publicités
éventuel parce que les nouveaux produits
qui s'en viennent commune à utiliser le
code promo sans filtre pour 20% de
rabais et le shipping gratuit vaille
pour sandra bhp gratuit en et demain
c'est beaucoup d'argent que vous sauver
après
la pole et bolt clean à
quelqu'un qui change votre vie
vous même ou la trémie ou votre cousin
va t'en va t'en merci mascaret
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
sait
hier
dom
félicitations même si on mène 2 200 et
la mc2 ça semblait hier mais en même
temps ça semble être well as mis la
concurrence à ces fous mène pas qu'on
avait décidé de commencer semaine 5 août
taille de même ça fait quasiment 4 un
creusement 4 à mende où est-ce qu'on
s'était dit on manque pour une semaine
puis on a tenu promesse en a pas moins
qu'une semaine pour la fête à un bouddha
de deux par semaine - puis c'est fou
mais non dre qui est tellement rendu
intégré que je me rends plus compte
qu'on a fait un bar semaine passée
c'est fou mais félicitations à toi
félicitations à - félicitations à nos
autres stars qui ont l'air un verre on
est en mode festif un petit peu le pour
le 200ème épisode moi je bois de la
schlague raspéguy way le commanditaire
officiel du studio sfr nouvelles sortes
d'essences nouvelles sont de série sur
moi je bois là sans alcool parce que
j'étais encore sans alcool et comme un
talent alcool fruits depuis ma fenêtre
en janvier le 15 janvier
mais j'ai revu certaines fois mettons un
verre de bulles dans des moments festifs
mais sinon un sans alcool depuis bombe
aux mains depuis je me sens
j'imagine je me sens mieux que si je ne
sais pas si je vais au fait qu'il
remercie vous remercie et merci les
autres stop il ya un biais du monde qui
nous écrivent encore qui était là depuis
deux jours un temps fou ça merci la
gagne parce que si vous étiez là depuis
le jour un geste de réflexion la
dernière main si les gens n'écoutent
depuis juin une écoute initialement
parce que
je sortais d'aude et puis on utilise en
a d'autres l'exorciste et vous nous
suiviez parce que vous étiez déjà
devrait peut-être dans le milieu de
l'influencé de la création de contenu
mais ton si vous avez reste accusé de
rester avec nous jusqu'à maintenant en
manquant pas un épisode ou peut-être
maman quand quelques-uns vous avez vu
passer charisme en des affaires qui sont
pas du domaine de l'influencé
j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'au début
on était
le monde du jeu dans les commentaires
mais ton ou d'un team est allé dans les
stades de monde les suivais ça sera
quand même vraiment changé pour un début
c'est rend plus jeune c'était vrai en
plus j'aurais ceux qui suivent les
influenceurs puis ceux qui écoutent audi
de mars en face on est des parts de zain
un peu aussi parce qu on a on recevait
beaucoup plus d'eux de gens de ce monde
le laisser ouais mais ça va évoluer
maintenant je me suis quand on parle et
quand même constater ce qu'on se disait
genre imagine juste dans un an
tout ce qu'on va avoir tout les gens
qu'on va avoir rencontré tout ce qu'on
va voir ce qu'on va voir à prix tout
doux où ça va nous mener philomène kasma
quatre ans plus tard c'est comme s'il
était là maintenant il ya le studio qui
existe en soi des podcasts qu'on produit
c'est que ça vaille
c'est cesser ces fous qui justement tout
le monde veut pas te manque on a
rencontré des amis qu'on s'est fait des
contacts qu'on s'est fait des
connaissances qu'on s'est fait d'aider
ces foules étaient mes entier on nie
qu'elle en parlait justement dans notre
dernier podcast qu'on a fait ouais ce
que
mentionnait qui attire des gens qui se
lancent un podcast pour rencontrer des
personnes c'est méthon l'entrepreneur
qui reçoit françois anbar c'est le fun
parce qu'après soit son numéro de
téléphone puis si tu leur cross country
mais comme tu dis mais le nombre de
personnes qu'on cif qu'on ne rencontre
et qui maintenant mettons
interagissent avec nous le dit ne
serait-ce que que des amis maintenant si
olivier bernard india desjardins qui
sont d'un couple d'amis maintenant comme
quand on connaît bien tu
j'ai pas fait le roi qui main qui nous
invite à son lancement et yannick de
martino ton ami tu sais tout sur tout
c'est tout souci de ce genre déjà qu'on
a rencontré deux par le père joe un mois
la première fois j'ai rencontré joe
c'était seul sans filtre puis c'est
devenu un de mes bons amis
aujourd'hui le fake c'est fou mais ça me
fait capoter
le succès des studios puis de sans-fil
tchéquie qui quand même kellogg est
présent un bon
prix mais il est justement aussi tout ce
qui est ce que ça nous a amené
personnellement humainement c'est ce qui
sait qu'ils baissent loin ouais d'accord
avec toi puis puis là avec le 200ème
fait que si on voulait prendre la peine
de venir ici mais on voulait aussi faire
un jardé todd sans filtre parce que
après quatre ans je pense qu'il faut
faire un petit check up nous hissons on
s'en parle depuis depuis un petit bouton
a caressé l'idée de peut-être arrêter le
sang filtres
pour pour plein de raisons aujourd'hui
tout seul pendant les prochaines heures
loin de compenser qu'on faisait qu'on se
rende à 200 pick et qu'on arrêtait oui
parce que tout soit des raisons mexique
ont amené à près de 200 conversations
aussi
mou des fois j'ai l'impression de me
répéter on a l'impression que tu sais
j'ai fait le tour d'une idée ou d'un
concept qui
puisse appeler aussi le monde du podcast
ne change d'ici
au début tu es tout le monde se
garrocher propos pour faire des podcasts
pitié savoir-faire des podcast
maintenant c'est comme un petit peu plus
compliqué que pour des raisons peut-être
caramany aussi on doute on a le goût de
décès d'une nouvelle offre à ses dunes
les projets tout le temps comme un petit
vent de fraîcheur est imminent a
maintenant fait que mais là on a dormi
là dessus on a dormi sur cette question
là puis moi j'ai eu une conversation
avec nicole amené qui m'a un peu fait
rêver nicole tu nous écoutes tu repasses
intitulé yes la kiffer nichols pour
intervenir à mais ça ça m'intéresse
podcast mais j'ai une conversation
amicale puis il me disait tu sais il me
fait réaliser en fait que
une place où est ce que par exemple
benoît renaud je vais prendre son
exemple parce qu'on leur suis vraiment
dernière mal qui est un chercheur
vraiment reconnu dans un domaine
extrêmement précis mais dans le domaine
universitaire qui peuvent venir sur
notre plateforme puis
avoir littéralement plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui peuvent
écouter ce qu'il a à dire mettons nicole
me faisait remarquer que ça se faisait
pas vraiment eu que si nous on ne
faisait pas ça se faisait pas vraiment
puis
ce point l'homme a fait remettre en
perspective un petit peu j'ai remis ça à
table qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est-ce que je commençais à trouver
l'homme étendu du sans fil depuis de la
répétition à toutes les semaines de
recevoir tout le temps des gens puis
j'ai comme réalisé que ce pataquès que
je commençais à trouver lost est
l'espèce de de recherche de quelqu'un
qui a une tribune me tromper de
quelqu'un qui du domaine public que le
tout ce monde là ils sont déjà invités à
toutes les portes car comme tu
mentionnes sont des gens peut-être mais
pas de gaz du monde entier puisqu'elle a
ya emmené il ya un temps limité dessus
mais qu'est ce que j'aimais
particulièrement du projet puisqu'ils
allaient si on arrêtait complètement me
manquiez profondément ses podcasts lotis
puis c'est pas qu'à cela c'est ce qu'ils
sont le mieux reçue pratiquement
en termes de cote d'écouté en terme de
temps d'écouté en termes de de rétention
de l'eau d'histoire de commencer en
termes de commentaires qu'on reçoit y a
personne qui vient me voir dans rue en
disant
je veux vraiment pas donner un jeu prend
le nom de quelqu'un que je connais pop
et qu'on n'a jamais reçue juste parce
que juste pour le byetta cause pour
permettre personnes anti du bus n'y a
personne qui vient board qui me parle du
podcast avec catherine le vaccin sont
infestés il vient de me voir pim part du
podcast avec sonia lupien avec roger
godbout avait mpi avec cdd guillaume du
le monde vienne parler de ces podcasts
lotis puisque j'ai réalisé en par
michael que si on arrêtait sa salle est
vraiment vraiment manqué
wapiti un espace aussi
si on sait jamais le dos ni ligne
directrice que le sans fil tpiy souvent
le monde bosse est question non mais
c'est quoi votre pote angle ou c'est con
à votre ligne directrice puis je combats
ne pas vraiment métier au final il ya
une qui crée au fil du temps par nos
personnalités people qui conte et
hippiques et
2 heures les
essayer d'être le plus exact possible au
niveau
l'étude elfe est loin du show sont
factuels la science la paix de l'esprit
qui sait
puis la nuance aussi médecin c'est deux
choses que je pense qu'ils sont comme
essentielle tes dents dans le paysage
metal picchi qu'on a vu que ça fait
depuis que ça peut faire quand il a
disparu
sally le sae lidice pour pouvoir penser
à tout ça ça fait autant d'affaires puis
ça fait les conspirationnistes piste
réactive
je pense que dans ce secteur où est-ce
que genre
le dialogue puis la nuance c'est de plus
en plus rares au piquet les gens sont
plus en plus camper dans l'opinion
s'était pas là encore avec moi
n'est pas mon ami mais
je pense que d'avoir un espace parce
qu'on peut
réfléchir un peu à voix haute savoie une
techno trancher sur quoi que ce soit
mais justement discuter de manière
ouverte et ouvert d'esprit phi phi
nuancé ça fait du bien puis souvent les
mondes qui m'approchent qui me disent
qu'ils voulaient sans fil qui veulent
discuter c'est souvent du monde comme
ceux
qui sont pauvres ni genre moi je suis
folle gauche ou folle droite où je suis
pour aussi coûté six mondes qui
réfléchissent
qui veulent en discuter
pis à ses fans ouais vraiment 100% si
j'ai eu et ça me fait penser ce que tu
viens juste de dire à une conversation
se passe il disait que j'ai eu avec
quelqu'un sur instagram si je reçois
plus des millions de messages que
j'essaie de répondre aux gens qui me
quittes méprenne prennent la peine de
m'écrire façon constructive maintenant
c'était suite à une conversation qu'on
avait eues au tour de joe gilgun déclare
toute l'espèce de canso culture autour
d'eux des failles de
cette espèce de polémiques là
puis on a eu dix étaient clairement pas
en accord avec avec mon point de vue qui
est qui était de dire que effectivement
mais faut que quelqu'un mette ses
culottes pour que pour établir des faits
quand c'est quelque chose qui a une
aussi grande tribu l'ancien puits
mais ça c'est juste terminer par com un
échange super constructif avec quelqu'un
qui avait pas la même opinion que moi
puis c'est ces gens là qui est coûteuse
sans filtre puis c'est pour ça que c'est
le fun tu fait finalement après avoir
cheminé
on n'était pas prêt à dire adieu aux
sans filtre je pense parce que ni toi ni
moi étions réellement prêts à ce que ça
se termine notons le a fait la paix avec
le fait qu'ils allaient se terminer
ouais ben je pense qu'on a eu des
des forces de deuil inversée parce que
je pense que toi quand c'est plus toi
qui as amené l'idée d'arrêter
puis moi au début timide de reconstituer
mouvementée où je me serais vue
construit ce hadith amsterdam
puis en même temps je sais ce que je
dois faire à 12.6 le début qu'il faut
pas le faire mais c'est la vie puisque
avec le pit et en même temps les raisons
étaient plus que magic et les jets
évêques - chicomba était l'ami avant
leur gueule
puis
nous un comité un choc je pense qu'on
sait comme évidemment recroiser parce
que c'est le chaland forte acceptation
annoncé comme acquis au repos mais y est
parfait mais
mais c'est ce même aussi j'ai réfléchi
beaucoup mais moi j'étais plus en mode
justement bon comme en convient qu'est
ce qu'on fait pas de quoi le prochain la
fin mais bien content de continuer puis
justement voter comme le montrent et la
semaine passée
de retourner de l'autre mais ton jeu
qu'on sait faire des choses confie dans
votre monde puis le genre je re goutta
au contact direct parce que l'on est et
ermites pendant dix-sept buts
puis
justement que les gens reviennent qui me
parle de son fils puis genre sont là et
moussa je vous écoute vraiment
assidûment des genres est 12 ème puis
j'aurai
j'ai pris quelques parler des lions puis
de débattre sa d'affaires c'est comme ça
m'a fait prendre conscience de
2,2 ce que si tu mets moi ces mots le
chemin s'est faite à linverse parce que
quand on a décidé d'arrêter ouais
on a on s'est dit on était à peu près à
l'épisode 191 le ceux qui nous écoutent
en ce moment tu fais qu'à peu près deux
mois et demi jean puis on s'est dit ok
ben pour les pour les derniers on va
recevoir nos amis on va recevoir nos
nous préférer le fait que l'on ne fait
pas de castaic adamo cendres et qu'on a
fait
enfin pas de cast avec poésie jo on ne
fera pas de castaic vittorio tu sais on
a fait on a vraiment hadid qui est venu
dire on a encore su nos preuves qu'on
voulait recevoir aussi extrêmes alphone
puis mois faisant ce j'ai fait puis on a
reçus benoît renaud aussi entre
tendances et podcasts le témoin faisant
sage ses locks comme j'ai quand même
fait amen c'est pour ça qu'on fait c'est
pour ça qu'on fait ce peut-être que on
s'était perdu un peu puis à cause de
crise qu'on a expliqué hausse tantôt
dans les têtes l'épisode 75 à 190 me
trompe peut-être aussi perdu un peu dans
cet épisode le du moins moi système
feeling que j'avais puis comme la
passion était plus nécessairement là
sauf que là car on a fait les deux
derniers géants fête christmas et c'est
ce qui est atlantis et c'est ça qu'on
faisait au début c'était ce qu'on
faisait au début on recevait des
scientifiques des gens à qui on chip
mais des spécialistes mettons le ou mais
déjà qu'ils ont tu laisses nom puis puis
mainstage tests physiques comme de fait
si les podcasts genre les gens nous en
ont parlé ils sont écoutés genre mais le
maire que des coudes en ce moment qu'on
a eu depuis le début du sans filtre
l'eau tu es dans les cinq dernières
semaines ne t'ont fait que j'en ris je
suis comme retomber en amour avec ce
avec le fait de la femme et ont fait qu
bref tout ça pour dire que ce qu'on a
décidé comme espèce 2
2 d'un compromis mais un jardin
pour pas que pour qu'on a encore le fun
le fun à faire le sans filtre sur pau
quelque chose qu'on fait conscient qu'il
faut absolument trouver quelqu'un pour
6h exact pour jamais pour gm est booké
quelqu'un parce qu'on 1 5 1 sans filtre
a formé tant pis pour que ce soit pour
qu'à chaque fois ça a été ce soit dans
le funk ça me tente vraiment puis ça me
tente vraiment parler des sujets
on est venu à la conclusion que
exact fait qu'on on vous laissera en a
200 en respectant notre notre règle
règlement de 1 par semaine sincèrement
ce qu'on a fait sauf que là vous aux
histoires sans filtre ont fait un
nouveau serment maintenant qui est qu'on
fera plus un par semaine fait qu'on va
réduire la cadence à combien on ne sait
pas exactement quand
mais chaque fois qu'on va être le ca va
etre pas certain d'être le petit
puis ça va être un pas de casse pardon
qu'on va aimer qu'on va être dans le
moment picon sera pas en train de juste
rentré au bureau et ongles qui puisse a
je pense que c'est la clé est d'avoir
envie d'être là à chaque fois telle
espèce de petit feu qu'on avait
initialement comme dans n'importe quelle
relation le cas ramené faut comme tu
relances un petit peu le feu dit puis
une fois qu'on a fait tout au long de
son filtre aussi puis on le fait souvent
quand même
ce soit que sur longue période de temps
mais on s'est souvent challenge qu'est
ce qu'on faisait t on souvent on dira
qu'il a le genre c'est quoi la nouvelle
affaire pour le sans-fil tu sais quoi
qu'on peut faire pour relancer le truc
pour produire ce que ça fasse pour
pâques je suis chaque fois on le fait un
genre de 4,5 fois pendant l'histoire du
sans fil de jusqu'à décide s'assoient
ensemble leur histoire mais deux camps
qui comme un conte se sort de ce bateau
qui est quand même qui a pris le placent
piqué il peut juste tranquillement
continuer à aimer ton mais à chaque fois
on essayait de faire de quoi de nouveau
puis là c'est un peu ce j'ai
l'impression d'un peu d'essayer de faire
quitte chaque envoi puis aussi l'autre
affaire c'est qu'on
on voit aussi diversifier un peu ce
qu'on fait individuellement c'est un
point qu'on peut qu'on peut aborder
temps à parler un petit peu tant
d'autres ces tours et au vent ce moment
fait que ça va quand même demandé chacun
du thym
extraits j'étudie au sf météo l'un tire
toi musée que sa porte et le rapport
pour de vrai d'un million d'affaires de
compans par la poule ben oui oui on peut
parler de vraiment
on dirait que je vous embarque dans la
période de six à tout le temps était
de tibou ça fait dans le fond à 14 ans
je fais de la musique l'attentât fait
peut-être dix ans que je fais ce que je
donne ma vie et que
ça a tout le temps
été de plus en plus ce n'est jamais une
période où est-ce que genre
c'était le thème or le team genre plus
j'étais là qu'est ce que je fais est ce
que j'ai ce que j'arrête
je vais me permettre un commentaire ça
n'a jamais été ça parce que
tu avais tout le temps peur que ça
devient de ce fait j'en connais
tellement peur qu'ils emmenaient ya eu
un passage à vide que tu faisais juste
comme tout le temps tout accepter fait
que ça faisait que tu avais jamais pensé
david parce que tu faisais tout le bois
oui mais des fois tu peux avoir pas dire
oui à tout mais qui présente juste rien
à dire oui puis ça peut donner sa
profession puis
j'ai travaillé en estie toute ma
vingtaine
puis comme on était là sans penser j'ai
mis du temps
gratis pini me genre des trucs pas payer
ou des trucs un peu tout croche pour
apprendre pour
pilule l'impression que
tout ce que j'ai ça me vient exalté le
comment ça commence à rentrer et et puis
le bon c'était mettons pour donner coûte
d'exemple moi je pense était depuis la
pandémie chez plus de studio chez plus
l'enregistrement chez plus de la
réalisation
puis pour ceux qui me suivent savent t
il j'ai fait l'album avec ariane droite
que la région réception est super bonne
elle sa carrière c'est comme si c'est
fou fait explose vraiment et c'est
vraiment bien on fait des shows eu tout
le temps du monde sinon dans le monde
connaissent les paroles par coeur de se
tourner c'est vrai c'est
j'avais j'ai même même imaginé
vivre un projet de compo de kate a
participé ou est-ce que le monde
connaisse le hic ce matin parce qu'ils
étaient des shows que j'ai fait que
jouer des toons d'un autre puisqu'elle
montre des paroles pourtant
intéressant de rocles
mais d'une tunique et à travailler petit
c'est ariane qui se composait l'étude
mais si on les a arrangés ensemble on
les a travaillés ensemble on lise
déconstruit en sambre refaite et virer
tout les bas puis c'est un long
processus piloté qui finalement ça sorte
que
ça existait pas l'aventuré facile et ça
ça existe
le monde reçoivent le monde est mondiale
au chaud puis le monde va en quarts dans
une salle au complet chante les paroles
que tout ça fait deux ans que tu entends
il ya c'est vraiment un grand
particulier comme feeling puis c'est
vrai puissant faites puis
laxiste face à ça
elle sera en plein plein des sens unique
cible de cris pas prêt d'arrêter ici
comme sur des buttes chaumont le premier
chaude depuis que l'album existe et puis
les 10 moyennement denses a le monde
craint qu'ils étaient venus lodosa
brasseur
match à partie ces jardins soir qui bat
au rythme du drom l'aja ses autres ouais
ça flashe wapiti et c'est vraiment un
talent mais ne me sentais vraiment des
choses dans des shows punk qui gère
qu'on allait au secondaire cégeps et la
petite salle mène les jeux tout le monde
est trop dedans exact mais oui ce cpl
c'est quand même pop mais avec toujours
une triste
ccpo c'est ainsi que ces gens c'est tout
ce que tu as déjà entendu mille fois
mais ces quatre chips et pop mais à
l'avenir d'énergie
punk un show
live bros cette cession
d'actifs acquis c'est vraiment le fait
que c'est ça à sa pop c'est pas près
d'arrêter pile il ya une foule de trucs
sigle qui ne me sont arrivées un peu
développe un mot je ne savais pas que je
suis en faire leur métier patrice
michaud m'a demandé de faire une tournée
avec lui ce qui est quand même un pic le
témoin patrice michaud sein des artistes
au québec tu penses tu pas sur le fait
qu'ils soient venus sur le podcast à
aider ouais ouais c'est quand même parce
que batista beige kaki ouais parce que
ariane dans sa boîte d'oeufs puis aussi
parce que son guitariste simon
d'enfoncement paix de nous avoir joué
bach ça fait longtemps que ça fait huit
ans qu'ils mouillent j'allais le voir
jouer les covered encore ses élites
marchois puis qu'on faisait du tout un
ensemble qui verra si ça a été même un
peu ce galeux
vraiment puis il s'est probablement
pôles métiers un genre de menteur parce
que j'allais le voir toutes les semaines
qui georges essais d'absorber ce sont
sont son jeu hector puis comme comment
qui comme un kit eco musiciens qui est
vraiment vraiment beaucoup vraiment
beaucoup inspiré qui tout a suivi qu'est
ce qu'il faisait pour comme un peu
essayé de marcher dans ses traces simple
fake piles huiles alfonsi pris sa place
dans ce bel été le grand emprunt fait
que
enfin qu'on se connaissait bien petit sa
vie que comme quelqu'un avait besoin de
quelqu'un pourra compter sur moi fac le
fait que moi je le connaisse bien qu'ils
avaient une bonne ration puis que leur
plus avoir rencontré patrice s'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui
sait
aller chercher quelqu'un pour partir en
tournée avec c'est
c'est une grosse décision quand même la
personne parti cdu que méthode connaît
pas personne un peu et ça passe par
lucien ce poste avec ricky maintenant
puis au final il est pas mal plus de
temps dans une tournée qui se passe
sur le stand j'ai fait que ces deux auto
save en gaspésie la fin mai début juin
si un éditeur dans la vanne bien du
temps à l'hôtel puis laissant tchèque
petit succès fait que
optimale marsan tarbes en cas persuadé
que ces mots justes et chansons tu
tentes et dans les bennes parce que là
c'est est à l'harmonie piétine ses
métiers en plus
patrice il me semble un go
100 go qui est vraiment une bonne partie
qui me ment genre qui est juste que
jusque là et je pense qu'il faut
s'entourer de monde aussi que devrait
jouer à des jeux dragon
bus
fac bercé ce jeu parce qu'ils étaient
victimes ni sur podcast que les
commissaires on s'est bien entendu il
n'ya pas samoëns effet qu'est ce qui se
raconte à
qui l'autre personne aussi qu'avec qui
jouera en tournée cet été puis ça a fait
comme si on parlait de ce que les
podcasts pu nous amener qu'on n'aurait
jamais soupçonné bête 100 et 200 femmes
enfants participent à ce que c'est le
passé jo
ça va être le fun c'est lui c'est des
gros festivals
grosse affaire des grosses têtes des
milliers personnes ça va être chaud
cette annonce et métiers il ya même des
shows j'ai vu là dans le calendrier aux
states et fait que
s'arrête sur dexter c'est très excitant
qui est je viens de me lancer là dedans
sinon city depuis
l'album d'ariane est sorti je me fait un
peu plus remarqué en tant que
réalisateur d'où ce que j'ai dit mon
team et cribles à youtube titre contre
alliances en studio enfin des trucs
ensemble que
chaque
semaine top it et c'est justement ça va
te demander du temps qui se mêlent
attire plus que temps mais maintenant
mais mais c'est cool man c'est faux
kenya puis tu parles de faire aussi un
podcast musicale c'est un autre favori
dans le fond quand quelqu'un qu'on s'est
parlé je me suis mis à réfléchir bon
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait
si moi je me suis même demandé le
sans-fil petit existe et mettons tout de
suite je vais arrêter de jouer sans fil
peut exister simple sans péage que ce
soit juste - ou ceux qui menacent notre
forme ou je sais pas trop tu et puis en
même temps ça tout le temps et nous deux
c'est toute notre force est d'être bull
ça aurait peut-être pu métier finalement
cette idée le kit est de faire un autre
pas de casse complètement
où est ce que je veux plus rien savoir
du monde du monde la musique face à un
peuple uni chez ca vas t'en veux pas de
casque on parle plus de musées plus des
questions plus pointues de gens rient et
4h très sutton lequel effets de prix
notamment du fait que c'est sûr que
c'est moins grand public que sans filtre
mais en même temps
il ya un public pour ce
fac pitt six mois ont encore une fois
dans l'optique de rencontrer du monde
qui apprend vite et dans un milieu dans
lequel tu sais c'est qu'il sait vraiment
c'est maintenant le fait de faire de la
musique puis le fait de jouer avec des
rampes personnes font par apprendre des
trucs qui vont servir sur ce podcast le
puits ses podcasts le les gens que vous
rencontrez puisque ce que je vais
apprendre les échanges observait aussi
dans dans mon médecine du site explique
hommes
ça fait quand même sans ça
j'ai toujours l'impression de toujours
dit qu'on fait le podcast parce que
j'adore le podcast
piété jamais été plus envie d'arrêter
pas-de-calais mais j'ai jamais non plus
penser fac je sais pas qui est mon cas
ça fait 4 heures mais moi ça fait 12 ans
ne sait quel sport ainsi que l'effet que
ça n'a jamais été c'est tout le temps
était saoul c'était toujours été là pour
des spots 1 pis
ils vendent moins que je rencontre dans
le monde de la musique qui ont qu une
des quelques parties de poker
puis encore plus de monde mais sur les
quatre caches mecs qui viennent me voir
qui me confient qu'ils me voyaient je
croise sur le stage c'est pas le gaz
barca c'est autre chose
lo'jo et
aux derniers jours l'ariana sherbrooke
elle vient me voir ils s'y mêlent à la
barbe et les cheveux longs c'est comme
son personnage mais c'est comme si je
joue comme je pense que ça marche que
sur la plage
chargé de piloter
mais quand je fais le job et jean
allaire cacher des
packages pour le show d'ariane déjà ce
qu'une fausse moustache des lunettes et
un gros nez
mais bref les sentiments de double ville
des jeux que qu'est-ce que je fais
quelque chose un peu de semaine de jour
pineau d'affaires la fin de semaine
puisque que j'aurais vraiment
l'impression de
batman batman akham le genre pour aller
faire un répit
je peux les quais les cartes graphiques
et les superman mais je me suis pas ça
pas de casque le ca ca unifie les
montois fake je peux encore de nos jours
encore de de rien c'est juste un embryon
d'idées
mais en même temps comme on l'a dit la
semaine passée faut pour ce faire il
faut juste le farm en dessous c'est la
chose la plus difficile facture
peut-être que le temps justement tenter
de gagner afin - sans filtre peut-être
le mettre là dedans mais je veux tu
attendras fin de l'été avant que sont
simplement fou on ne sait pas trop on
verra je lance ce puits c'est quelque
chose qui vous intéresse le monde qui
nous écoutent un podcast parce qu'on
reçoit plus des musiciens des artistes
qu'on parle de musique
dite
commencé commenté commenté sam été
requise à l'écouté comme ce jeu ça va me
donner un petit coup penalty pour la fin
ouais ouais c'est ça c'est souvent ce
que ça prend parce que je sens que ça
intéresserait que seulement des gens
surtout que tu es ma tante tient avec
tes des connexions sur ce rythme
intéressant sans aucun doute les tifs
est sûr que ça serait trop petit et
beaucoup de monde qui aimeraient chose
n'est-ce pas ouais ouais affecte souvent
en bas de gasny calmont un podcast
oscille que que temps pas de casser quoi
yes on est entrain de on est entré de la
borie tout seul on va commencer qui
devrait s'appeler la messe la messe on
veut sortir nos épisodes le dimanche
tara c'est
[Rires]
exact fait que très peu de cas ce que je
pars avec et avec ma mère amie claudia
dans le fond pis puis on a toutes sortes
de toutes sortes de sujets le service de
ressembler m'attends à ce que thomas
fait avec deux reprises
fait que ça risque d'être votre carte
juste nous deux entrepôts pour le début
puis
qui on va jouer toutes sortes d'affaires
à bâtir ont pensé mais ton analyse est
d'aider des épisodes de black mirror ou
des films qu'on est con qu'on a vu ouais
des livres aussi chic et grand fan de
d'albert camus pile absolue c'est
l'absurde tout ce à quoi on sert à quoi
on s'embarque là-dedans vraiment pied
si on veut faire des épisodes de
dilemmes moraux aussi
ce genre d'affaires le fait quoi on va
commencer de même qu'ils puis on en
coupe de
cotiser aussi pour pour des invités mais
je pense qu'on on va commencer par faire
des épisodes tout seul tu en entends je
pense qu'on aurait des invités pour un
sujet en particulier mais ben ouais ça
s'en vient la mi mai on commence à
enregistrer ce puis je sais pas quand
est ce qu'on va commencer à les sortir
mais ça devrait pas tarder non plus très
cools et autres manifestations merci
et
les écoulements petit citoyen tabac
mardi le type d'analysé des oeuvres puis
de plonger dedans mais ne mets toi qui
est ce ma semaine tu veux crise mange à
apprendre le pigeon
qui épiait si je sais
moi partant si je deviens de plus en
plus à l'aise ou si je pense
qu'ils mènent j'ai vraiment marqué le
pas de calais la semaine passée était
bondée vraiment bon puis gentil cas je
te vois avec les filets c'est que sarah
lucic je trouve que c'est vraiment mais
n'était rendu fucking à l'aise merci
c'est vraiment gentil et qui fait quoi
je pense j'en arrivais j'en arrivais
comme le fait longtemps je me fais tout
à poser la question quand je me plains
pas de cash l'appui ce serait quoi
maintenant ton était ton et des podcasts
site en avez un et tout ce montage mais
je m'en fais parler puis à un moment
donné c'est je pense c'est josée hallé
claudia justement pierre disait qu'il
voulait peut-être comme réorienter un
peu son réaligner sont pas de casse ou
qui bref qui puis peut-être la fois avec
quelqu'un d'autre c'est parce qu'elle a
la veine coanimatrice au début quand
elle participe le man et son sac ou
entre ces partis fait que l'aller
faisait tout seul depuis un bout tu fais
est quelque chose qu'il a travaillé ici
et puis jouer en jasant nous juste fini
par dire manette et moi ça fait
longtemps que je me fais tout le temps
posé la question qui honnêtement je
pense que de toutes les personnes avec
qui je pourrais me partira pas de cas je
pense que l c'est vraiment là vraiment
la baisse le tir on est on est déjà
choisi comme des joueurs de tant pis si
on se connaît vraiment bien fait que
fait que ce soit je pense que je pense
je pense que c'est une bonne idée mais
je pense à
ses côtés projet moi même moi je lançais
si j'ai lancé une pique en janvier mais
compagnie pick-up ce qu'écoutent qui
connaissent pas et pick-ups et des
suppléments du sport d'endurance
puis il a lancé un peu comme un genre de
à faible risque c'était vraiment un
genre de puis moi comme je parlais
l'épisode ex andric puis adamo
maintenant moins investir mon argent
dans l'immobilier ou ou des la bourse où
les celi mettons le jeu je connais rien
se fait juste d'y penser maintenant ou
jamais la nfc depuis la crypte autre
juste pensé assassin's creed l'anc
simonetti pilotes les investir d'argent
l'agenda non mais c'est ça je te
ramasser ça je te dis moi mois pile et
j'avais de l'argent en plus le recul le
ton la fin de l'année passée
j'avais de l'attaqué mois ci se portent
les raisons dans le temps que j'avais de
l'argent j'avais de l'argent puis je me
dis ah qu'il est je veux je veux lancer
quelque chose parce que je voulais mais
je voulais me rapprocher du sport ce que
je trouve que je m'en éloigner qui se
meut se faisaient du sport beaucoup ma
plateforme 1,5 g ce n'est que de
l'entraînement nautique puis fait que je
voulais me rapprocher du sport fait j'ai
lancé cette compagnie le pis était
vraiment faible risque les gens on n'a
pas investi beaucoup investi l'argent
que j'avais métier c'est pas tant que
sur piste elle sait pas s'il allait
rechercher mettons si jamais on voulait
juste faire ce genre
une fois les sauva tu vas t'en des
ventes alors je vends mon inventaire
vont arriver à 06 heures et j'étais
quand même un peu de
peta a perdu ma tâche créé un produit
que moi j'avais envie fait que dans le
pire des cas j'avais des sacs de poudre
pour trois ans puisse arrêter ce type
sauf que le finalement il ya eu un
espèce d'engouement
vraiment inattendu
inespéré
pour ce produit le ca le jeu encore
encore à ce jour je comprends pas qu est
ce qui se passe parce que comme à chaque
jour j'ai plusieurs commandes qui rend
depuis le monde ont recommencé à
recommander plus je reçois des
recommande puis comme
la boule commence vraiment à faire boule
de neige sur hull puis effectif ce
projet-là commencé comme dans dix ans je
ne prends pas prendra pas me prendre
trop de temps comme maintenant faire
genre crise a peut être
urgent ça pourrait être le studio pixar
est ton avis le facilement puis ce
projet lot et le studio
jam les podcasts j'aime les
conversations ça se rapproche le plus de
mon parcours en littérature le cd
l'intérêt disons universitaire
l'attention veut fait qu'il y avait cet
aspect là qui était comble et l'aspect
sport l'était comme pas du tout le tir
je fais du sport d'excellence pendant 25
heures par jour se passer non parce que
parce que je suis pas payé pour faire
sur ces gens ça pouvait pas être ma job
tandis que le jeu pouvait comme impur
trouver ce que j'avais à l'université
c'est à dire comme de quad
intellectuellement vraiment motivant
mais aussi le sport puis c est l
entièreté de ma vie à l'université
triple pourrait comme retrouvé
l'entièreté de ma vie que j'aimais
vraiment beaucoup mais comme maintenant
dans l'âge adulte et fait que fait que
c'est ça quand j'ai réalisé que sa levée
j'ai comme décidé de faire qui joue à
mettre du temps c'est là dedans puis
fait que l'on me développer de nouveaux
produits racheter une autre commande
commencé vis à cet été ça va vraiment
être le fun parce qu'il ya plein
d'événements que je vais sponsorisés
puis je vais aller sur place très avec
des traits ron des triathlons des
compétitions d'olibeau est ce que
j'aurai mon petit kiosque tu vas
rencontrer des athlètes je veux leur
faire goûter le truc qui joue tout seul
c'est genre un échange avec des athlètes
que moi me nourrit kissman petit fait
que je vois sur le terrain et je dois
participer à des événements puis ça va
vraiment être pas je suis vraiment aux
événements que ça revienne pis
parallèlement à ce jeu me suis dit qui
est tanné qu'on a reçu le podcast
question voulait faire des podcasts on
peut faire des podcasts cas on veut les
personnes qui nous empêche de faire des
pas de gassion faire des pâtes ya ce fut
je me suis dit que
je voulais me lancer un podcast pour
l'entraînement fait que recevoir des
sportifs des entraîneurs des
nutritionnistes des des physios des
quines juste du monde pour parler
d'entraînement parler profondément le
sport puis juste pour les geeks de sport
dans le fond puis ça ça va être un
premier sas vélo pick podcasts et le nom
ma compagnie puis je te dis just do it
mes invitations sont lancées déjà puis
en train de boucler des invités il y
aura pas de fréquence précise mais mais
ça va se passer puis ça c'est chris
manger qui se marre de faire ça avec le
fait aussi de cela qu ils s'enfilent
droit un peu va me permettre de mettre
un petit peu plus de temps de ce côté là
puis l'autre truc est important à
mentionner aussi je retombe vivent à
québec dans mes projets je retournais va
québec en juillet fait que par défaut de
faire la voix trop souvent comme ça fait
maintenant
ça va ça va ça va se jouer entre ces
deux villes qui veut-il faire le cam et
en tue farissi tout le faire chez vous
et le faire vraiment je m'arrangeais
pour le faire ici puis peut-être aussi
que je m'achèterai un genre de setup
portatif lé genre de set up portatif
après ça je pourrais envoyer les
enregistrements calme et ont pu gérer
seul de loin je mets ton chat québec où
s'est amené mettons en avant dès 20h et
que voir des athlètes largement à
quelqu'un sait attendu qu on congèle
part avec son directeur fait que
toute cette future l'homme de ma vie
avec le studio broadcast puis genre tout
ça on dirait que d'un derniers jours sa
main comme réanimer il ya un aspect de
marbre encore de ma vie qui va durer
encore pendant quelques quelques mois
quelques années peut-être qu'ils vont
drainer monétairement et
émotionnellement mais il ya toute cette
beauté là comme l'homme fort c'est de me
concentrer là-dessus pire puits s'écoule
maintenant je compte en comptant la
réception des gens aussi tu sais moi de
la vente j'aï seul fort la vente jean
ainsi de vendre quelque chose à
quelqu'un maintenant le jeune
sauf si tu crois profondément à ce que
tu veux quand on va mettons des espaces
publicitaires pour le sans-fil podcast
chic ça vole ça vaut ce que les gens
vont payer parce que chez que les gens
qui nous écoutent mettons ils sont ils
sont engagés aide envers nous pouvons
porter attention à la pub qu'on lit tu
sais je leur fais pas payer pour un
espace suffisamment descendre de son
petit mais aupic a c'est la même chose
système en produits que de la bombe moi
que c'est facile j'en les commentaires
je reçois ce n'est que si c'est juste
comme ça c'est juste la meilleure chose
que j'ai testé deux comme en termes de
nutrition sportive nautique avec une
fois que tout se mange en parle j'en
passe je veux juste parler de toutes les
personnes qui veulent travailler avec
moi professionnellement en termes de
collaboration partenariat sur mon
instagram fait que c'est comme un mal
pour un bien en ce sens où le jeu peu
juste par les métaphores parce que parce
que j'ai de la place publicitaires
mettant sur mon espace pour faire seul
fait que non si ce jeu c'est de voir le
positif oui quel but par semaine si
qu'on fasse
chacun des podcasts dans les domaines
qui sont ils nos domaines principaux de
vie qui ont gardé sans fil pour faire
des trucs sur un petit peu plus
sujets variés que des trucs les intérêts
qu'il reste le monde c'est sur la
moralité ou soit des idées des sujets
scientifiques ou soit et c'est comme les
diagrammes
celsa les deux essais voir ces métiers
là ce qui se retrouve au milieu le sans
fil qui se communique se retrouve au
milieu quand on est chacun une barbe et
si on fait un truc qui vraiment dans le
domaine
exact exact une fois que je voulais
contre chaque pile cela on va on va
avoir besoin de vous
les gens
qu'ils nous écoutent les gens qui
écoutent le sans filtre parce que au
studio sfr au studio vsf pardon on est
constamment à la recherche de
nouveaux projets de podcasts original
on cherche actuellement on entre dans
l'histoire du studio sf maintenant si on
fait la liste l'aide si on a quand même
une bonne feuille de route le tir on a
le sens fitr podcast sexe oral les deux
podcasts qui roulent encore présentement
on a lancé on est la création originale
est le temps de jeu avec et d'un mot
initialement qui était produit par le
studio sf
dite simplifiée dite en discute qui
était produit par le studio cette
production originale
le par le giaba changer de direction jay
a
rapatrié son podcast finalement pris une
pause dernièrement qu'on avait lancée
elle parle avec léa clermont dion qui on
produisait aussi on avait coproduit
le comité des idées dangereuses avec
gabriel dubois puis tout seul c'était
cdpa cast original originaux au genou du
studio sfr puis là on est à la recherche
de nos prochain podcast originaux on a
quelques idées sur le feu
sûr qu'on cherche peut-être encore une
idée est une idée de podcasts pour être
hebdomadaire bihebdomadaire maintenant
mais on cherche son camp si vous avez
fixé un podcast qui n'existent pas que
ce soit une personne ne s est
personnelle serait malakal un podcast ou
serait malade ou à bakassi vous écoute
et peut-être aux états unis que vous
aimez mettons que ce qu'engendre concept
demain mais au québec acq sudiste débat
qui fait un commentaire ou équivalent
privé aussi même peut-être visiteurs
inscrits soit le contenu ou au niveau
des quines personnalités publiques ou
d'un enfant que vous avez une idée de
projet pas de casse écrivez nous puis on
va regarder ce puits
sinon une journée il ya des passions le
produit est sinon le studio ici est
disponible pour nouveauté qui tu vois
c'est exact c'est parce que les
productions faut quand même que nous
avons sont capables de les monétiser et
il faut qu'il y ait une certaine portée
si vous êtes chez vous 2 des mendiants
j'ai vraiment une bonne des podcasts
lorsqu'on parle maintenant de 2 comment
créer des portes
ouais mais c'est aussi des idées un peu
à la cecc soral way où il ne se serait
pas que ça n'a presque pas le sexe ça
peut ne pas réparer quel sujet qui est
possiblement que il va devoir de nouveau
parce qu'on va le tout à fait tout à
fait pipi pied aussi l'hôte affaire
parlant du studio parents de
l'allocation de podcasts on en parle
souvent au début des dépôts de casse
mais on peut peut être en parler plus un
peu en profondeur dans les derniers que
ça fait six mois à peu près plus que
ceux se ses mots et maintenant qu'est
qu'on est là qu'on l'ait rendue dans ce
cas ci on ne
sait ni document on n'est pas des go
manuel dedans vie puis
on a déménagé de laquelle quand vous
avez remarqué en étant on n'est plus
dans notre studio sf une initiale puis
on a triplé l'espace qu'on avait pour
créer trois espaces aux studios
différents pile au moment où est-ce
qu'on vous parle il reste un cadre
accroché dans l'eau studio qui s'est
terminée les rhénans du studio sf sont
seront officiellement terminée dans un
moment vous à l'écouté ça ça va être
fini fake
ça fait du bien mais ça fait du bien
parce que astique a amené je le croyais
pas mais je pensais pas qu'on allait se
sait qu'un con parce que dans à travers
tout ce on a quand même
investi beaucoup d'argent dans ce move
lol beaucoup beaucoup d'argent contre
crée plus
on a des histoires segatti note avant
noël ont été comme en mode et sa voix
bien studio on a grandi et on l'est on
construit un mur on achète du stock des
nouvelles caméras de nouveaux micros
petites cibles s'installe qui le on a eu
des difficultés
qui a fait en sorte que nous revenions
drastiquement descend de la
geôle à main on investit dans du stock
on a un noyau qui ne coûte plus cher
c'est comme au on n'avait pas prévu ce
qui on est ce qu'on veut survivre
il
aujourd'hui au plus foutraque on va
surveiller mais lieu des soirées où
est-ce qu'on était à deux jours de tir à
plomb a passé une posture vais vraiment
on a passé proche on a passé extrêmement
proches ont il a fallu qu'on modifie
dans notre fonctionnement il fallu qu'on
concours pas beaucoup de place fin du
combat
qu'on dise bayadh et des gens qui nous
étaient chargés fallu qu'on conjuguait
avec beaucoup de logistique mais
finalement on s'en est quand c'est rendu
on s'en est sortis pilonnent fini les
raynaud complètement les trois studios
sont 100% opérationnel
on a des plantes on a des cadres comme
vous voyez derrière moi on a tout effets
du café ça compte du café on n'a fait
qu'assurer on/off la bière avec ou sans
alcool un service clé en main de
création de podcasts on l'avait imaginé
ça fait longtemps qu'on s'était dit dans
l'autre côté dans le studio constat d'y
aller le tout les podcasts confesse on
dans le même secteur faudrait
diversifier on l'imaginait on a décidé
de le faire on apprend que ses proches
ne pas réussir on le fait puis le sait
disponible si vous écoutez vous caresser
l'idée de lancer un podcast pour vrai
alesi aucune raison de parfaire c'est
vraiment abordable nos prix sont
vraiment nettement le sait quasiment
ridiculement abordable va falloir faire
quelque chose à propos de se
faire quelque chose mais si vous
caresser l'idée progressé vraiment sans
un mouvement et si votre podcast effet
puis obligé d'avoir des écoutes comme
nous on peut on a la chance de l'avoir
sur le sans filtre pour que ça vaille la
peine tu es si ton projet c'est si par
exemple une compagnie de voter même pas
obligé dans le pronostic c'était avant
que puis que tu veux discuter de droit
puis potentiellement au passage récolté
un ou deux clients supplémentaires
sipa deux cas c'est la meilleure façon
de faire ce pas ce que ton histoire est
tellement fidèle puis tu deviens il
saute devient tellement proches de toi
parce que tu entendes parlé une heure à
chaque semaine à chaque deux semaines
que ce genre d'affaires qui se passe ou
si tu veux juste rappeler ce juste ripé
sur faire un cadeau de toi toi je
souhaiterais faire un pas de qualité des
gens s p les triples nets reculs trip sa
musique trip soirée culturelle faisant
pas de casting en examen ont dit se
demande la culture la musique émergente
pige au crible
les tripeux pour
être exact exact fait qu'il soit aussi
qui écoule est fait
puisque c'est cool man point
positif dans tout mais il faut voir le
procès d'antoine le positif dans tout
pays dénué de nu tous unis mènent le
filet tourisme
-
huawei tous les thalys à cammas raflé
haïti tout dit-elle tétouan islamisme
je reprendrai les trois dernières années
sur quoi
mais
allez dans les taudis semaine je le
finisse en ski je pense qu'en ce moment
c'est le début imminent d'un volt d'un
cd boudin au nouveau début d'une grande
aventure même les débuter si le premier
jour du reste de notre vie
sera c'était une vraie france mais qui
pourrait faire un podcast de croissance
personnelle sans être trop de chizy mme
si je prends un coach de vie le jeu
quelqu'un qui comme un des buts gags en
scène - et en faisant pack est en cours
à nicolas situe avec son micro ondes est
moins intense le
fait pas qu'est ce qu'on attend pas
croissance a déjà huit roll qui reçoit
des gens qui se dépassent déjà qui est
toi même qui me qui toi
j'étais assez présent je suis passé pour
qu'il sait pas qui je suis assez présent
non mais dans ce sens qui était ton
podcast qui parlent autrement dit par
les
inévitablement de dépassement de soi
même pas notablement déjà repoussé ses
limites notamment des genres
pour savoir un gars qui a monté les
vraies cela dit pis que oui oui oui pour
lui de l'avoir fait avec du pick up et
je veux partir et quinsac
ouais pareil 200 épisodes de
félicitations et merci à tout le monde
de nous écouter
c'était pas de vous
le répète sans fil on aurait pu on
aurait jamais eu elles auraient
peut-être plus parlants 2 épisode 3
épisodes
ouais c'est pas trop cédé 0,12
dans safari 4 iphone mais très dense
merci la gagne haut la salue on faisait
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
pataquès combien
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le pitchoune pitch vous abonner pour
trop dollars par mois sans trop de longs
mois et trois pièces par morlaàs par
mois et vous avez les pas de carte en
avance acquise avec les premiers de
votre groupe d'amis alors voir écouter
les podcasts puis avoir pouvoir avoir
une avance quand vous allez tuer la
dynamique entre les amys tout le temps
avons une avance sur les jobs en avance
ou des centres de toi mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que
lâcher le podcast su ni voulu nous
entendre josé davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres après chaque pas
de castaic l'on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on vend jaser on va
être pile et nicole non nicole il est
maintenant évident comme un fils
travaille à plat ce détail est là mais
on jase on parle de conversion qu'on
m'aide à voir mais ce si vous voulez
avoir accès sur
ben heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous s'est excusé
sur pétulant il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous